today on the matte wall show a major
scandal as leaked emails revealed the
democratic mayor of nashville was
covering up covet 19 data in order to
fraudulently continue the lockdowns he
didn't want people to know that bars and
restaurants actually
were not significant vectors for
transmission so we'll talk about that
story and also ask
given everything we've seen recently why
would anyone vote for a democrat to run
their city or state
also five headlines including trump's
patriotic education as he calls it
initiative
and also a video of an unhinged woman
berating a cvs employee for calling the
cops on shoplifters
and our daily cancellation will cancel
the people burning j.k rowling's books
because they're mad that she believes
that men have penises
it's a good reason good a reason as any
to burn a book i suppose all of that
on the way but first a couple of very
important notes first of all i want to
tell you of course about our very good
friends that uh rock otto
you know if you're if you have a problem
with your car uh you have a few options
you know you can go
to the mechanic and you can sit there
you can pay a lot of money and go to the
auto parts store
uh and wander aimlessly around the
aisles not knowing what you're looking
at or i think a much better option is
just go to rockauto.com
so much easier than walking into a store
the other part about walking into at
least if you're me and you're not an
expert
in cars you're gonna get you're gonna
get pelted with all these questions you
might not know answers to
and you're gonna feel very emasculated
that might just be a me problem i don't
know but either way
no problem there with rockauto.com you
carry around at
in your pocket at your desk you have it
on your laptop rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
they're not going to change prices to
you know sort of
get as much of as they can out of you
they're going to give you the lowest
price they possibly can rockauto.com
family business honest business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years
and uh you can go there rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds and hundreds of different
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com
are always reliably low and uh they're
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
and they've got that great selection
everything you could possibly want very
easy to navigate as well
so go to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car truck
and write walsh in there how did you
hear about his box
so that they know that we sent you okay
um the local fox affiliate in nashville
has obtained leaked emails that appear
to show cover 19 cover-up among city
officials
at the mayor's office but this was not a
cover-up to hide how bad the situation
was
as you know trump and others have been
accused of doing erroneously
on the contrary they didn't want the
public to know just how safe and
unthreatened they actually were so this
is from the fox report by dennis
ferrier says the chronovirus cases on
lower broadway
may have been so low that the mayor's
office and the metro health department
decided to keep it a secret emails
between the mayor senior advisor and the
health department reveal
only a partial picture but what they
reveal is disturbing
the discussion involves the low number
of coronavirus cases emerging from bars
and restaurants and how to handle that
and most disturbingly how to keep it
from the public
uh the report goes on on june 30th
contact tracing was given a small view
of coronavirus
clusters construction and nursing homes
were found to be causing problems with
more than a thousand cases traced each
category
we knew about that of course with the
nursing homes uh but it says but bars
and restaurants reported just 22 cases
leslie waller from the health department
asks this isn't going to be publicly
released right just
info from the mayor's office correct
this is from uh
senior advisor benjamin eagle says
correct not for public consumption
a month later the health department has
asked point blank about the rumor that
there are only 80 cases traced to bars
and restaurants
tennessee lookout reporter nate rao asks
the figure you gave of
more than 80 does lead to a natural
question if there have been over 20 000
positive cases of cover 19 in davidson
and only 80 or so are traced to bars and
restaurants
doesn't that mean restaurants and bars
aren't a very big problem
health department official brian todd
asked uh five
five health department officials please
advise how you recommend i respond
and um and then here it comes this is
the most important part the name of the
person who gives this response
isn't known apparently it was clipped
from the screenshots that was that were
sent to the news channel
but this is what somebody says my two
cents
we have certainly refused to give counts
per bar because those numbers are low
per site
we could still release the total though
and then a response to the over 80
could be because that number is
increasing all the time and we don't
want to say a specific number
the article that goes on to say the
authenticity of these emails was
confirmed by a metro staff attorney
so what do we have here we have a
democratic mayor
shutting down bars and restaurants
putting thousands of people out of work
ruining countless lives eviscerating the
local economy
and all on a false premise that he knew
apparently to be a false premise
but in fact the situation is even worse
than it sounds
let's look at let's look now at another
local media report
this is from uh the nbc affiliate in
in nashville on july 2nd of this year
on july 2nd the city reverted back
to the more restrictive phase 2 of their
reopening plan
they had been in phase 3 which allowed
for bars to be open in a limited
capacity
um allowed restaurants to operate at a
moderately reduced capacity
but then on july 2nd they went back
bars had to be shut down again
completely for two weeks
restaurants had to reduce their capacity
by another 25 percent down to 50 percent
from 75 percent
a local musician in the in in the city
uh messaged me yesterday
and said that you know bar owners were
blindsided by this because they had
already opened up
they'd also stocked up for the holiday
weekend they were coming up to july 4th
and then out of nowhere they found out
about this in the media
um they were shut down and much of their
product went to waste
the mayor though said this in a
statement at the time this was uh
in in right before july 4th weekend he
says nashville faces another challenge
in a season of challenges
our phase three has not been effective
we are going to go back to what we know
is effective in slowing the spread of
the disease
beginning friday july 3rd and for the
next several weeks at least nashville
will revert to a phase two with
modifications
of the mode roadmap for reopening
nashville
the modified plan is tailored on what
we've learned through contact tracing
investigations
over the past several weeks it is in
response to sharp recent increases and
clustering of cases
okay well we know now from the leaked
emails the contract tracing
uh contact tracing rather investigations
really showed that there was
no reason for bars and restaurants to be
closed at all there was no
medical reason for him to do this so
what was the real reason
well it might be worth noting that a bar
in the city in fact one co-owned by kid
rock
as it happens um filed a lawsuit against
the mayor not long before
this phase two the sequel was debuted
so was the mayor punishing the people
that were suing him
was he trying to make things look worse
because it would help him with the
lawsuit
we don't know but this is a massive
scandal anyway it's also worth noting
something else
and and i got several messages pointing
this out
and i i looked it up to confirm it the
mayor's son
was was set to graduate from a swanky
private school in the city at the end of
june now under phase two
he couldn't have an in-person graduation
but the mayor went to phase three
coincidentally
right in time for the graduation and
then back to phase two
right after huh
now let's zoom out and take a wider view
the democrat mayor in nashville
apparently hid covet data
data shut down bars and restaurants for
no justifiable reason
the democrat mayor of chicago shut down
her city while continuing to get her
hair done by a professional stylist even
while threatening her citizens with
arrest for doing the same
meanwhile crime and violence plagued the
city in chicago she does nothing about
it
democrat mayor of new york one of the
most incompetent and embarrassing public
officials in our nation's history
he's been stumbling his way through the
crisis in disastrous fashion
trampling on the constitution every step
of the way let's not forget this is the
same guy who threatened to shut down
churches permanently
if they defied him democrats democrat
mayors of portland and seattle
they let insurrectionists run their city
for weeks and months on end
democrat mayor of minneapolis laid down
in the fetal position while mobbs burned
his city invaded his police stations
burned his police stations to the ground
he went to george floyd's funeral and
wept before the golden casket
democrat mayors of la atlanta kenosha
very similar things what you find all
across the country where democrats are
in control
is chaos crime economic regression and
stagnation
filth misery the breakdown of law and
order
this is what you find these are people
unfit to lead half of them should
probably be in jail
but why i think that's an interesting
question why why do democrats make for
such
abysmal leaders the fact that they do is
is is very apparent but why
i think there are a few answers to that
but here's one thing to consider
democrats put ideology first
forever and always in all situations
this has made them effective culture
warriors
more effective than conservatives and it
makes them effective activists
and it makes them effective brainwashers
of our children
they are very good at exploiting any and
all avenues to spread their satanic
gospel but governing a state or a
country or running a city
dealing with real problems and crises
pandemic riots crime
gangs drugs homelessness that requires
practical
skills but democrat governors and mayors
are all lawyers career politicians
activists laurie lightfoot in chicago
she's a lawyer bill de blasio started
his career as a political organizer
the mayor of seattle is a lawyer mayor
of los angeles is a college professor
he's been in politics for 20 years he's
only 49 by the way
these are people who don't know the
first thing about leading managing
solving problems
because they're activists attorneys and
academics and politicians
and it shows now i say all of this
but i don't want to make it sound like
they really want to do the job well but
are a bunch of blundering fools who
can't
figure it out they are blundering fools
but i don't think they actually care
about doing the job
i don't think they care about the people
they lead or even like those people
that's another problem with democrats
they're conditioned practically from
birth to hate america and most of its
inhabitants
how can you lead people you hate how can
you lead people you don't understand a
guy like ted wheeler in portland
he doesn't understand anyone on any side
of any issue
doesn't understand the left-wing
radicals he's appeasing that's why they
hate him
they ran him out of his apartment in the
middle of the night he doesn't
understand the normal people what
dwindling few remain in the city who
just want to live their lives and run
their businesses
doesn't like them either or care about
them or what happens to them
and that's a common thread that links
all of these people together
and it's why you don't have to be a
republican this isn't a pitch for
republicans
but if you vote for a democrat to run
your city or your state or your country
you are asking for disastrous results
which you will surely
get let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well when you spend a lot of time um on
the internet as
as i certainly do and i think we all do
and you are right now which is good i
want you to be here
uh you leave yourself wide open to the
bad guys there are a lot of bad people
on
on the internet who have uh devious
intentions shall we say the fbi cyber
division is warning that students and
families will be increasingly vulnerable
to cyber attacks
because of the current online learning
and the use of teleconference
applications you think about all the
kids
right now kids are already spending way
too much time online and now so many of
them are hours a day on
on school online even young kids since
the start of the pandemic there's been a
300 increase in cyber crime activity
hackers are becoming more sophisticated
and taking advantage of teleconference
accounts
through which they are pawning
informations like like emails and
passwords
uh which is why it's really important to
have a first of all have a conversation
with your kids about protecting their
information
you know tell them the threats that are
out there uh and and help them with that
but this is also why you need lifelock
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet and lifelock detects a
wide range of identity threats
like your social security number being
for sale in the dark web and if they
detect your information
um they will send you an alert and uh
and if there is a problem they're gonna
help you
get yourself and restore your identity
um as well so nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can find out if your information is for
sale on the dark web
get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
scan pick the plan that's right for you
save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
walsh that's a free scan at lifelock.com
scan and 25 off with promo code
walsh
okay um let's go to our headlines
number one president trump yesterday
unveiled something called
the 1776 commission which he established
by executive order to promote patriotic
education as
as he is selling it here he is
explaining
today i'm also pleased to announce that
i will soon sign an executive order
establishing a national commission to
promote patriotic education
it will be called the 1776 commission
thank you it will encourage our
educators to teach our children about
the miracle of american history
and make plans to honor the 250th
anniversary
of our founding think of that 250 years
now i i like the idea as we as you know
as we talked about yesterday
i think this actually uh it works with
the topic of the show yesterday uh
our education system as it is currently
run churns out people who both
hate and are ignorant of our country and
its history and its traditions
and this is unique by the way this is
this is not
normal it would be hard to come up with
an example of an education system
in any other country throughout history
that had the goal
of turning future generations against
the country itself
that's how our education system operates
that's not a normal thing
now granted the whole idea of having an
education system in a formal sense is
relatively new but even so
ours is suicidal and self-destructive by
design
and it's good that we would do anything
to combat that i'm in favor of that
with that said two points number one um
i would prefer if we called this
truthful education i think truthful
education rather than patriotic
education
because the problem with what the kids
are taught about america
in schools it isn't that the lessons are
unpatriotic
it's that they aren't true the idea that
america is fundamentally racist
um that's not an unpatriotic idea well
it is unpatriotic but
that's not the problem if it was true
then i would say
yeah kids should learn that kids should
learn the truth in school even if it's a
difficult truth
the problem is it isn't true so it's
untruthful
so i would prefer truthful education but
patriotic
education is okay too and the second
point is just
keep in mind and remember there is no
initiative
that can change the fact that our
education system is dedicated to
left-wing indoctrination
that is what it is fundamentally at its
core that's not going to change at least
not overnight
it will take generations that's a
generational change
and i know for me when we talked about
this yesterday i got some emails from
people saying
well you know if you abandon the
education system and you're not fighting
to change it then you're part of the
problem
you know what when you say fight to
change it what you're saying is you want
me to send my kids in
and have my kids fight to change it no
you know that's not my kid's job
my kid's job at the age of seven is not
to fight for changes in the education
system
it is my responsibility to make sure
they are educated
not their job to to change society
they're not they're not prepared for
that
they're not ready for that um so it's a
generational change but
frankly my kids are not going to be part
of making that change happen um
also by the way trump i wanted to play
this he attacked critical race theory
during his remarks and the media didn't
like this at all let's listen to this
clip
a perfect example of critical race
theory
was recently published by the
smithsonian institution
this document alleged that concepts such
as
hard work rational thinking
and the nuclear family and belief in god
were not values that unite all americans
but were instead
aspects of whiteness
this is offensive and outrageous to
americans of
every ethnicity and it's especially
harmful to children of minority
backgrounds who should be
uplifted not disparaged
teaching this horrible doctrine to our
children
is a form of child abuse in the true
sense of those words yeah my only
problem with him calling critical race
theory child abuse
and a lot of leftists were upset about
that my only problem is that he should
have said
that it is putrid noxious garbage and
also child abuse
but what he said is totally true as well
unassailably true
uh number two from the daily wire 33
republican lawmakers added their names
to a letter that
representative jim banks sent to
attorney general william barr on
thursday urging him to prosecute netflix
for distributing child pornography in
the latest addition to the backlash
against the netflix cuties movie which
depicts
previous and girls in sexually
provocative situations banks and his
colleagues condemned the streaming
platform and called for them to be
prosecuted
uh and that's what they they sent the
letter to bar for i don't know if this
is actually going to happen
but it should and i've been saying this
for a long time
that standing up against filth and
degeneracy
standing up against the sexualization
and corruption of children
that is not only the right thing to do
um but the great thing is it's also
extremely popular
it's an extremely popular position if
only the republicans had the guts to do
it and
finally it takes republicans a while to
figure this figure things out but
after a few decades they've figured this
out and so this is good
number three lady gaga in another
courageous moment from a celebrity has
come out
you're not going to believe this she has
come out against white supremacy
i know pretty pretty pretty risky
position for anyone to take especially a
celebrity
so this from the daily wire says um
quoting her
i am in the process of learning and
unlearning things i've been taught my
whole life
wait i'm in the process of learning and
unlearning
things i've been so first she's going to
learn them and then she's going to
unlearn them
why not just don't learn them to begin
with and then you don't have to unlearn
them i don't understand this
she says when you're born in this
country we all drink the poison that is
white supremacy
social justice is not just a literacy
it's a lifestyle
none of this means anything nothing that
i just read means anything
she continues what do i think about
posting a black square
i think everybody has a different
feeling about a black square
do i think there's such a thing as
performative activism yes
do i think there's been true activism
that's been very important
yes do i believe black lives matter yes
do i believe this is going to get louder
yes do i believe it should
yes do i ask myself questions that
nobody else really cares about
yes the last one was for me not her uh
so a lot of very courageous
positions here um just to just to
summarize she thinks black lives matter
um she's not in favor of white supremacy
and she thinks that uh that as far as
posting a black square
some people do it and some people don't
those are her opinions
bold number four now here's something
that's really bold okay let's go to real
here's some real courage the governor of
nigeria's kaduna state
has signed a law saying this is from the
daily mail by the way
saying that men convicted of rape will
face surgical castration
and anyone raping a child under age 14
will face the death penalty under the
new legislation
it follows public anger over a recent
increase of rapes amid cover 19
restrictions
which prompted the nation's state
governors to declare a state of
emergency
um the uh says one of the officials the
drastic penalties are required to help
further protect children from a serious
crime
i i would be absolutely in favor of that
in this country
you know i think it's it's sort of
absurd if you're going to have capital
punishment
the idea that the only thing that can
earn the capital capital punishment is
killing someone
um there are crimes you can commit that
are
at least as bad as murdering someone
oftentimes worse
raping a child would be one of those
things
that's never going to happen here but i
would be certainly in favor of it
five finally this really could have been
my daily cancellations it was it was
kind of a tie between this and the one
that i'm going to do
so this maybe this is daily cancellation
1a
and i'll tell you what you're going to
witness here in this video
this video is the divide in america
right now
the two people in this video represent
the two sides of america
it's almost not even ideological you
have reasonable guy on one side
and insane harpy on the other watch this
may i ask so i live in the neighborhood
um and i
have come to the cvs very often may ask
why you called the police on those two
men cbs policy
dictates that if they're shoplifters the
exit store with
merchandise unpaid for it yeah we should
get the police involved and if the
police apprehend them
so i actually did not elect the press
charges i said hey look i just want them
to know they can't come in here anymore
because they shop with you and i just
need them to sign that and i need my
collector and the officer supplies and
the guy says same thing
thank you it's not your merchandise it's
the store
so you know what happens when the
pokemon or black people
and you decided to call the police on
two black people that stole
that allegedly took something from the
store
because you're willing to uphold the
policy and they could have lost their
lives
we can agree to disagree on this because
i don't work for you
and i don't need i follow my company's
policies not your policies where i can
appreciate anything
so you're willing to risk someone's life
for what thirty thousand dollars a year
that's
there was no risk in my opinion thank
you
you have a great night what is your name
my name is no what is his name
no one's gonna tell you my name when
you're sitting here videotaping us so
that you've been trying
enlisted some sort of violence it's not
gonna happen illicit violence against
you you just elicited violence against
two black men by calling the police on
them so we got to walk away when one of
them had a warrant it could have been
arrested and the cops still let him go
just
listen to yourself you work with black
folks you just remember that
yes you see if if um if somebody commits
a crime
and you call the police and they get
hurt
probably while assaulting the cops it's
your fault for calling that's the point
that that woman was trying to make
now this is this is obviously insane if
you find yourself sympathizing at all
with the woman in that exchange and not
with the guy
who is i mean that guy give that guy a
raise uh he's
he's a manager for cvs he's not paid to
deal with this
but um this guy is incredibly reasonable
articulate
and explains yeah it's patient as well
way more patient than i would be this
guy deserves a massive raise
but if you watch that exchange and you
find yourself
at all sympathizing with the woman then
you need to reevaluate your whole life
but you are but that that's the side
you're on and you you're there's a very
clear dividing line here
it is it is good guy bad guy and you see
in that exchange there there's a very
clear good guy bad guy
um but there's something more insidious
going on here
it is the first thing that came to mind
when i when i watch this
because keep in mind that in some of
these high-profile police shootings
the one in lancaster uh for example
kenosha with jacob blake
another example and others as well
very often it's a it's a woman it wasn't
the case here but but
very often it's a woman who calls the
cops because
she's being threatened or abused by a
man
so then the person in this video and
this this is what you hear from black
lives matter and antifa as well
this is a common attitude but what is
she saying
she's saying apparently if you're a
woman being abused by a man
don't call the cops but if he because if
he gets himself shot when the cops come
because he's a violent lunatic um then
it's going to be your fault
i mean how many women who are faced with
the next jacob blake will hesitate to
call the cops
because they know with their based on
their experience with this man
that he's a violent lunatic and if the
cops come then he might get himself shot
and so the woman's gonna worry well if
that happens you know my life's gonna be
over too because everyone's gonna blame
me like this
this this crazy woman and people like
her are gonna blame me
uh so that's something that that i
really worry about but again there's the
dividing line in america just decide
whose side are you on let's get to our
daily cancellation all right today we're
going to cancel
uh book burners now this should be a
cancellation that i'm doing in 1930s
germany
not modern america but as always those
who allegedly
hate fascism have a funny habit of
copying its
methods and it's happening yet again so
here's the newsweek report it says
a new tick-tock trend has enrage has
emerged this week as former harry potter
fans protest author jk rowling's widely
criticized views on trans people
by burning copies of her books uh one
video posted by a tick-tock
user shows a number of harry potter
books being placed on a burning pyre
you have to stop using death of the
author as an excuse to have your cake
and eat it too the voice over says
while the reader's perspective is an
important part of interpretation and
meaning it is impossible to completely
divorce a work from its creator
the voiceover continues the positive
impact that jk rowling's work had on
millions of readers
does not negate how her hateful lobbying
has affected the trans community
this doesn't even touch on the harmful
fat phobia
oh she's fat phobic now too i hadn't
heard about that racism and
valorization of supremacists and child
abusers in her most famous work
the video ends with a message your love
of harry potter is not more important
than the lives of trans women well
there's a false dichotomy if you've ever
heard one in my life
you have to choose between those two
things either harry potter
or quote unquote trans women you can't
you have to choose between them
now um and you can see in the video here
one of the book burnings happening
um now why are people mad at jk rowling
well this goes back of course to the
controversy that rowling stirred up
months ago
when she first came out as a believer in
biology this is a very stressful and
dangerous thing for any celebrity
or anyone who runs in left-wing circles
to be exposed as a biology believer can
have serious consequences in their lives
for it to be found out that you believe
that men have penises
um this is the kind of thing that can
ruin your life
jk rowling that's she's discovered that
ever since she admitted publicly that
men had penises
many of her previous fans have had this
vendetta against her
now this was ramped up this week when it
was reported by pink news
which is one of the most atrocious and
dishonest left-wing rags in existence
and there's a lot of competition for
that title
uh it was reported that jk rowling has
written a transphobic novel about a man
who dresses as a woman to kill his
victims
and their tweet about it which you can
see right here has 35 000 retweets with
thousands of people reacting in horror
based on a headline about a book that
they haven't read
and the irony is that many of these
people who are who are
freaking out about this book they
haven't read these are the same ones who
said that you can't judge the netflix
movie cuties without watching it
now of course you could try to argue
that the knife cuts the other way too
and i said you can judge cuties without
watching it but here i'm saying you
can't you can't judge the book without
reading it
doesn't that make me a hypocrite no it
doesn't and i'll tell you why
here's the difference cuties is a movie
which means the scenes with the young
girls in sexually compromised positions
that actually happened they really did
that
the filmmakers really had young children
act that way and they filmed it
so you can absolutely object to filming
11 year olds twerking
without watching 11 year olds twerk the
same way you could object to
someone drowning puppies without
watching them do it
a book is different nobody is hurt
in the making of a book it's entirely
fiction it's just
words so you can object to certain acts
being committed against children
without seeing the acts but it doesn't
make sense to object to words being
written
without first understanding the context
of those words
hopefully the distinction there is clear
and i don't need to dwell on it anymore
um now other media outlets have jumped
on the pile
the daily telegraph for example reported
that rowling's book
is about a transvestite killer and the
moral of the story is
never trust a man in a dress
and i think this is from someone who
also didn't read it but they're telling
you what the moral of the story is
now personally i think that's a fine
moral
and good advice and in fact if you call
that statement never trust a man in a
dress
transphobic then you're saying that
the person in the dress is a man so
wouldn't you be the transphobic one then
by your logic
um in any case it turns out that this is
all being blown out of proportion
unsurprisingly madeline kearns has a
piece about this in the national review
this is what she says according to nick
cohen who reviewed troubled blood that's
the name of the book
after actually reading the book
transvestitism barely features in the
plot um
when it and when it does nothing is made
of the fact that the killer wears a wig
and a women's woman's coat not a dress
as a disguise when approaching one of
his victims cohen describes the work
which is the fifth installment in
rowling's
uh komoron strike crime series as a
900-page novel that is
dickensian in its scope and gallery of
characters it tells the tale of
strike and his business partner robin
ellicott who are hired by a middle-aged
woman and to investigate the
disappearance
of her mother in the 1970s a mother a
character called dennis creed is
investigated because he was thought
guilty at the time
but a good dozen other suspects are also
investigated he concludes
you have to search hard to find a
justification for the belief that the
book's moral
seems to be never trust a man in a dress
so it's all bogus and in fact there's
nothing new or strange about a story
like this featuring a dude dressing in
women's clothes to kill someone
psycho uh alfred hitchcock has similar
themes
silence silence of the lambs has uh
themes in
that ballpark as well of course i
wouldn't expect these book burners to
know that because they've only read
one book in their lives harry potter and
even their knowledge of film goes back
no further than
about 2006. all of this
and when i look at the modern left in
general it brings to mind a quote from
c.s lewis
in his memoir surprised by joy and he
said
a young man who wishes to remain a sound
atheist cannot be too careful of his
reading there are traps everywhere
that's the quote and what he meant is
that for him
atheism seems to be a tenuous and
fragile worldview which can be easily
blown apart and so must be preserved and
protected by among other things
being very selective in what you choose
to expose yourself to
i think this applies even more so to
modern leftism though atheism and modern
leftism of course are not
unrelated but this is why we're seeing
you know book burning popping up again
because
knowledge information diversity of
thought differing viewpoints
these are a mortal threat to a world
view that cannot withstand the pressure
cannot stand up against the scrutiny all
it can do is shout you down
shut you up burn your book cancel you
burn a building throw a rock at you so
very often it has
physical responses to intellectual
challenges
and that's because it's intellectual
arsenal is empty
and you definitely know that's the case
for you if you find yourself burning a
book
and that's why book burners today are
canceled
that'll do it for the show and for the
week have a great weekend everybody
thanks for watching thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there